um the other night uh
sorry if i
it's hard kind of hard to understand
what i'm saying or if i have a list
because the other night i got a fight
with a black guy and
he punched me in the lip and the mouth
and
my teeth actually pierced through my lip
and uh through
the skin
of your chin yeah wow and so
i kind of have a lisp
is crazy isn't it
actually that was in macarthur park
are we good
yes max maxine hi yeah maxine maxine
uh so i was born
in bakersfield california
my mom
is
she she was using pills and i blew
uppers at the time and my dad he's
always used crystal meth
he was
in prison when i was born actually and
most of my childhood
he my mom and my dad never married
so my
mom ended up marrying
my uh step dad when i was about four
and he he kind of raised me and uh
i i know my mom has still has severe
depression at one point she actually
um tried to kill herself and she wanted
to take me and my sister my older sister
with with her um
how old were you
uh i think
five or six i'm not sure my sister's
nine years older than me how is she
proposing to do this um uh something
about
i i think
i'm not really sure
i haven't asked for details about that
story
but um
so my mom married my stepdad uh when i
was four or five
around that time and then i spent most
of my time with my grandparents because
both my mom and my stepdad were using
drugs
and my dad was in prison or using drugs
and
my older sister is my half sister so i
spent a lot of time with my my dad's mom
um
they basically
raised me from the first part of my
childhood
and um
my my stepdad was diagnosed with lung
cancer whenever uh
i was in fourth grade
and
he passed away
um
but whenever he was diagnosed my mom
they both cleaned up their act
and we had moved to colorado
before then and we came back to
california
and um when my stepdad passed away my
mom like
she was always a cool parent but she
kind of turned into
like the strict parent like she just
wanted the perfect family
and my older sister like was kind of
like
she she did what she had to do you know
like she she was a good kid
and she got a job and she wasn't much
trouble for my mom but i was always
really rebellious and
like from the age of 13 i was in and out
of juvenile hall
um
constant runaway
and
always
wanted to do something my mom didn't
want me to do piercings different hair
color whatever she always
didn't like anything i wanted to do
and i started using crystal meth when i
was 13
along with spice and
of course marijuana but
um uh
i lived in oildale in bakersfield which
is a
mostly white neighborhood if you're
familiar
and um
there's a lot of drugs out there and
i uh i was addicted to spice for two
years and i stayed on meth
unless i was in juvenile hall i was
basically using drugs
i remember one time i got arrested and i
weighed 92 pounds and i'm 5'8 so
that's like
really bad but um
i started i came out here when i was 17.
i
eventually my mom just said she didn't
want me anymore and i
got
sent
sentenced to placement in juneau hall so
i had to wait for a group home
and
they sent me out here to long beach
and uh
i after like a month there i ended up
running
uh from there and i've been in l.a since
i mean i've
you know cleared up i eventually
got sent back to bakersfield to clear up
my
uh
probation and stuff like that like
because i got caught up out here and i
visited but i don't see much of my
family anymore except for my dad my dad
actually he's still
is using but he
my birth dad we've gotten really close
but um
he moved back to bakersfield too
but when i came out here i was living on
the side of the freeway
um in a tent
and that's when i started slamming meth
and
and eventually heroin
and
i
actually would i
i would only use needles i wasn't i
stopped smoking everything you know
and my
ex-boyfriend my best friend
he uh when he we got together he
told me that
he would do anything it took to get me
to stop using needles
and
eventually he did
and
since then i'm not
i don't use them very often
and that i think that saved my life you
know like today you're using fentanyl or
yeah i'm using fentanyl i started using
fentanyl when i was 19.
like right around the first time it came
around it started to use the heroin
addict did not get exposed to fentanyl
yeah exactly
but
like i said my ex like he he saved my
life and
you know
i have a lot of love for him but our
relationship we were together for six
years and
our relationship just turned really
toxic like i was really abusive when we
got together
and
i
you know i guess eventually you're gonna
defend yourself whenever a girl punches
you in the face right after so many
times
but then it just turned into
like
a lot of physical abuse from him
um
but i think we're both equally
responsible for that you know
and
around
i was the scar on my face the one on my
nose my lip um i got that
when our dog was stolen some
girl was talking
[ __ ] to me and i
i was gonna beat her up and she
pulled a knife out and lunged at me
sliced me my teeth were showing through
my lips that time too
on top but um i was gonna go to the
hospital but i've never gotten stitches
i've never broken a bone
um
i
sorry i didn't i sat outside the
hospital for like nine hours
didn't go in didn't get stitches or
anything
but um
why is that uh
i'm scared
that no that too but i i was scared of
like i never
i don't like hospitals you know
but um
yeah like
recently
about a year and a half ago
my ex we we split up
and he
he left i think it's the only time i've
ever kicked like out of jail
because i i was so broken up like i was
standing on the corner waiting for him
for three days without
any drugs or anything
um
like he's the one who broke my front
tooth
yeah but um
i i
mainly
survived off of either
you know
stealing from stores or
you know
selling what i have or what i have to
and
that gets into sex work sometimes
um it has
once or twice but um
i try to stick to
not doing that
a lot of um
like kind of borderline
stuff like uh
i don't i'm
like like more like porn
but not i've gotten ripped off doing
that too so
i right now i'm trying to
i'm trying to figure out
how to get my life together
and i have been for a while but now it's
like
i don't know i was my most recent
relationship
was um
i i thought that was gonna work out but
it didn't and uh
that's whenever i started doing xanax
and honestly like
it's really hard
like maintaining multiple
addictions and
it's really hard like when
you
i have to do it alone whenever
you can't you don't have anybody else
and
you can't trust anybody out here that's
like the worst part
like sometimes i feel like
i'm losing it you know sometimes i feel
like that
i must be crazy because
reality like
if everything i believe in everything
i've trusted
like
things that like i believed like
people i thought were good or something
i thought was the right thing to do if
i'm always wrong like like
what's real you know like
i question reality constantly like
because like
you never know when someone or something
is like not the real thing
and it's like really really
i guess like it's hard for me because i
still have hope most of the time you
know like i still have hope in people
and i i try to see the best and the
worst people
because i just do it's who i am you know
i guess
maybe
it comes
like
i i'm depressed like 99 of the time
but i guess i get that from my mom
the
bipolar disorder from my dad
ocd for my mom
and
[Music]
self-medicating is like
it's it's hard to get your [ __ ] together
out of here every time you think
like you get an id you get your your
you finally think that your things are
like turning over and to a new leaf and
things are going to be better and
then it just
crashes down and
you lose hope yeah it's it's so
discouraging
you know it's like being in quicksand
you just
you can't pull yourself out of this no
matter how hard between between getting
ripped off every other day and
needing your fix and not having really
friends that you can trust
yeah and i'm like i'm like a social
butterfly like i'm out there and i talk
to everybody you know
and
[Music]
people like i used to be really
nice whenever i was still in bakersfield
and i got
i got taken advantage of
like people are constantly like
taking my kindness for weakness so when
i came out here i kind of turned into a
[ __ ] you know like i was really i was
also kind of spoiled you know
and um
i was mean to a lot of people i was just
playing mean i was a bully
and
uh
like not even really a bully i was just
mean i was a
[ __ ]
and
a lot of people now they they they hold
that against me and they they don't like
me because of it and
like i was just i was 17 years old you
know like i and i was with a guy who i
was miserable with
and
they like whenever he left me
i
i decided that
every day
i want to
do better and treat people better than i
did the day before
because
that's
the thing about drugs out here is they
stunt your growth emotionally physically
mentally whatever
and
but mostly only if you allow them to if
you allow to
allow yourself to
like recognize whenever you've done
something wrong or when something's not
working or when you've made a mistake
recognize it you can learn from it and
you can grow
and not be stuck is like
you know
in that
childish mental state
and
yeah the only reason i i got in that
fight with a black guy
the other night was because i was
let down again and
left out in the cold all night like
there's been nights whenever i just had
no blanket just sitting on the sidewalk
and
i try to take care of myself but it's
like
i don't want to live that way anymore
you know you can't live i don't like it
especially since winter's coming and
stuff like
but i was so upset
like i just wanted to feel something
else i wanted something other i felt
like i want to feel something i want to
hurt i want something else to hurt
something physical to hurt
rather than feel this emotional pain so
i went out and just like intimidated
this
i was actually trying to get my ex to
hit me but he he hasn't hit me in a long
time he's actually he's my friend and i
feel really bad for it it was actually
kind of [ __ ] up for me but he wouldn't
do it and this
black guy was like i would have punched
i would have knocked her out already and
so i was like whoops
and
i hit him first though
so
you're a fighter
yeah
i i smiled after he hit me i laughed and
i was like finally got what i wanted
but now like i have another scar on my
face and it really hurts and it felt
good last night because
nothing else hurt
you know like i was like
i like to fight though
it feels good like it it's
it's something like
maybe someday i can get into kickboxing
i'm only 23.
23. yeah
so what's my age again
do you have any regrets
oh come on
i regret a lot of stuff but
i don't think i regret them enough to
most of them like
big stuff i don't regret because
i regret a lot of the people i've hurt
but i don't regret like a lot of my
mistakes because i've learned from him i
wouldn't be who i am today
and i honestly think i'm a
better person i become a better person
with every passing moment because that's
life you know you grow or you don't and
you can't grow if you can't
recognize
what's not right you know
you can't learn
and like i'm a learner you know like i
i'm not perfect like i
i do have issues with being right you
know i'm gonna argue or i should have
been a lawyer or something
but uh
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your 23 years
you need to love yourself you know you
can't you can't do anything unless you
you have love for yourself
you know you can't you can't that like
just a little bit at least you know like
of
confidence in yourself that you can
overcome
[Music]
you're not supposed to like bury pain
you're supposed to overcome it you know
and
and
that that right there is lesson you
don't bury pain you overcome it
yeah all right maxine thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you for
hearing it and i wish you the best of
luck out there okay you're young you
have a lot of time to yeah
change the direction of your life
you